[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
und das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
Steinmeier warnt vor protestwahlen im
ZDF sommerinterview nennt der
Bundespräsident das umfragebuch der AFD
beunruhigend
wachsender Widerstand in Israel immer
mehr Menschen protestieren gegen die
geplante Entmachtung der Justiz
bis zu 38 Grad Deutschland schwitzt erst
am Dienstag kommt ein Ende der
Hitzewelle in Sicht
[Musik]
wir dürfen das Geschäft der Angstmacher
in dieser Gesellschaft nicht noch weiter
fördern so mahnt der Bundespräsident
angesichts der hohen Umfragewerte der
AFD eine Partei die zur Verrohung der
Auseinandersetzung Beitrage sagte
Steinmeier beim ZDF
sommer-katastrophe Andreas
der Bundespräsident geht voran das hier
soll ein gutes Beispiel sein kommt ins
Ahrtal sagt Steinmeier kommt zurück geht
wandern geht Essen so wie er an diesem
Sonntag könne jeder was für die noch
immer notleidende Region tun fast zwei
Jahre nach der bis dahin unvorstellbaren
Flut ist vieles vorangegangen vieles
aber auch nicht wenn richtig ist dass es
sich um eine jahrhundert-katastrophe
handelte dann kann und darf nicht
erstaunen dass auch zwei Jahre nach der
flutnacht Schäden noch sichtbar sind
schon zuvor im ZDF sommerinterview lehnt
Steinmeier Schuldzuweisungen ab auch
beim Thema Umfrage hoch der AFD erstmals
überhaupt liegen jetzt auch die
Sozialdemokraten im Politbarometer
hinter der in Teilen rechtsextremen
Partei ja die Umfragen sind beunruhigend
aber sie dürfen nicht dazu führen dass
wir jede kritische Frage
automatisch als Populismus und
Rechtsextremismus einordnen einen
Steinmeiers Aigner Verantwortung an
seiner Russlandpolitik reißt die Kritik
nicht ab sogar ein
Untersuchungsausschuss ist im Gespräch
wenn sie danach fragen ob wir eine
Aufarbeitung brauchen habe ich überhaupt
nichts dagegen manches würde sich bei
dieser Aufarbeitung auch korrigieren als
Außenminister hat Steinmeier im Namen
von Deutschland die Ächtung von
Streumunition unterschrieben anders als
die USA die sie der Ukraine jetzt
liefern wollen deshalb finde ich ist die
deutsche Position nach wie vor richtig
sich gegen Streu Munition auszusprechen
aber sie kann in der gegenwärtigen
Situation der USA nicht in den Arm
fallen es war Steinmeiers vierter
artalbesuch nach der Flut er wird
gemessen werden am versprechen wir
vergessen euch nicht
das ganze Gespräch mit dem
Bundespräsidenten können Sie direkt nach
uns sehen
zwei Tage vor dem NATO-Gipfel bietet
US-Präsident beiden an die USA könnten
der Ukraine nach Kriegsende
militärischen Schutz bieten wie Israel
Voraussetzung sei ein Waffenstillstand
oder ein Friedensabkommen mit Russland
der Prozess der NATO beizutreten brauche
Zeit sagte beiden in einem Interview mit
CNN die USA unterstützen Israel jedes
Jahr mit rund 3,8 Milliarden Dollar
jetzt sind wir in Israel dort sind
wieder mehr als
150.000 Menschen auf die Straße gegangen
die Demonstrationen seit 27 Wochen
richten sich gegen die Pläne der
Regierung die Rechte des Obersten
Gerichts zu beschneiden morgen soll über
einen ersten Teil der Justizreform im
Parlament abgestimmt werden Michael
Beverungen
Israel in Aufruhr seit fast 7 Monaten
protestieren Woche für Woche mehr als
100.000 Menschen gegen die sogenannte
Justizreform so auch gestern Abend die
meisten auf den Straßen von Tel Aviv die
Regierung macht ernst und will ein
erstes Gesetz durchwinken der Oberste
Gerichtshof soll Entscheidungen der
Regierung nicht mehr auf ihre
Verhältnismäßigkeit überprüfen dürfen
die Demonstrierenden sehen Israel auf
dem Weg in die Diktatur
das ist meine 27 Woche in Folge ich
kämpfe lieber jetzt statt später zu
bereuen dass ich nicht genug getan habe
das ist alles so geplant um Israel ins
Mittelalter zurückzuversetzen wir
kämpfen dafür so zu bleiben wie wir sind
wir wollen nicht wieder Iran werden
die Regierung findet dagegen die Polizei
greife nicht hart genug durch die
Protestierenden wollten das ganze Land
blockieren kritisiert Premiere tanjao
heute im Kabinett
Rechtsverstöße gibt es bei der Blockade
der Hauptverkehrsadern des Landes und
des Flughafens und wenn gefordert wird
keine Steuern mehr zu zahlen
die Protestierenden werfen hinter den
Jahr oder dagegen eine Salamitaktik vor
keine Überprüfung der
Verhältnismäßigkeit von regierungshandel
mehr das ist bereits ein massiver
Angriff auf die Gewaltenteilung die
Protestbewegung sieht darin aber auch
einen Testballon der Tanja aus sie
fürchtet netanjaro könnte trotz anders
lautender Bekundungen auch die
Überprüfung von Gesetzen durch den
Gerichtshof einschränken
morgen soll die Knesset in erster Lesung
abstimmen die Opposition im Parlament
und auf der Straße sieht darin einen
Dammbruch und will am Dienstag
tatsächlich das gesamte Land lahmlegen
seit Monaten Toben im Sudan Kämpfe
zwischen der Armee und der
paramilitärischen milizf nach einem
Luftangriff auf einen Wohnviertel nahe
der Hauptstadt Karton warnt
UN-Generalsekretär
uterisch vor einem ausgewachsenen
Bürgerkrieg mindestens 22 Menschen kamen
laut oder chinesischen
Gesundheitsministerium gestern ums Leben
die RSF wirft der Armee vor für den
Angriff verantwortlich zu sein das
Militär weist das zurück
im Schatten bleiben und viel Wasser
trinken das war die Empfehlung für heute
mit bis zu 38 Grad der bisher heißeste
Tag des Jahres in Köln tanzten
nichtsdestotrotz die Massen zum
Christopher Street Day kamen nach
Angaben der Veranstalter über eine
Million Menschen Anna Gürth
viele haben bunte Fächer mitgebracht zum
Christopher Street Day sie feiern alle
Formen der Liebe ausgelassen trotz
Temperaturen weit über 30 Grad vielen
Sonnencreme viel Wasser und einfach Spaß
haben ich glaube dann merkt man die
Temperaturen gar nicht ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich freue mich ein bisschen aus
Gewitter ins Wasser
in den Innenstädten staut sich die Hitze
ob in Köln oder wie hier in Karlsruhe
die Luft flimmert trotzdem flüchtet
manch einer nach draußen wir sind im
Dachgeschoss und Überleben gerade noch
so mit Ventilatoren und es ist echt also
ich dusch ich geh raus und ich bin
wieder nass ich liebe die Wärme und wenn
man dann noch im kühlen große bekommen
das ist perfekt
Erfrischung suchen die Menschen auch an
den Badeseen Plätze unterm Sonnenschirm
sind heiß begehrt auch im Norden von
Deutschland Hochbetrieb an den
Ostseestränden die hohen Temperaturen
aber besonders für ältere und
vorerkrankte Menschen ein Risiko das
merken sie vor allem in den Notaufnahmen
wie hier am Klinikum Stuttgart
dehydriert sind die einfach nicht genug
getrunken haben vor allen Dingen aus den
alten Pflegeheimen da haben wir schon
mehr Patienten heute ich würde denken so
25% mehr von diesen Patienten am Abend
entlädt sich die Hitze im Westen
Deutschlands in heftigen Gewittern mit
starkem Regen im Landkreis Wesel reist
der Sturm Teile eines Dachs herunter und
entwurzelt mehrere Bäume
und aktuell warnt der Deutsche
Wetterdienst vor schweren Gewitter mit
Orkanböen heftigem Starkregen und Hagel
im Nordwesten Deutschlands so und jetzt
zu dir Norbert den knapp einer Stunde
gehen sie zu Ende die Finals 2023 18
deutsche Meisterschaften an vier Tagen
ja und wieder ein riesen Publikumserfolg
an rein und Ruhe in Berlin und in Kassel
dort finden die Leichtathletik
Wettkämpfe statt und dort holte Gina
lückenkemper heute ihren zweiten Titel
einen Tag nach ihrem hundert Meter
Triumph hat Europameisterin Gina
lückenkämper auch ihre Berliner
Vereinsstaffel mit Nadine Reetz Michel
Janiak und Leonie kluvik zu Gold bei den
nationalen Meisterschaften geführt und
das mit deutscher Jahresbestleistung für
Staffeln Turner Andreas Toba kann es
kaum glauben mit 32 ist er noch Mal
deutscher Meister am Reck geworden das
ist ihm zuletzt 2019 gelungen und am
Schwebebalken triumphiert die ehemalige
Weltmeisterin Pauline Schäfer Betz
[Applaus]
das B als Abkürzung für Breakdance und
b-girl you ist seit heute Deutsche
Meisterin vom nächsten Jahr an also
bereits in Paris ist Breakdance übrigens
olympisch
19 etappe der Tour de France 182 km von
Leonardo bla auf dem berühmt berüchtigen
erloschenen Vulkan mit bis zu 14%
Steigung am Schluss Sieger der Kanadier
Michael Wutz vor dem Franzosen per Regie
lato Formel 1 Weltmeister Max Verstappen
aus der Niederlanden hat seinen achten
Saison Sieg eingefahren diesmal beim
Großen Preis von Großbritannien in
Silverstone 2 wurde der Brite Norris vor
dessen Landsmann Louis Hamilton ja und
beim tennisturnierten da ist alles mit
Alexander Zverev der letzte deutsche
Einzelspieler ausgeschieden
mit einem Ast beendete der Italiener
Matteo berettini das hart umkämpfte
Match der Hamburger unterlag trotz
seiner starken Leistung mit 3:66 zu 76
zu 7 die beiden letzten Sätze wurden
also im tie-brick entschieden
aber es gibt ja noch Kevin Krawitz und
timpage die spielen noch als deutsches
Doppel im Achtelfinale wie schön danke
schön
es bleibt heiß und gewittrig morgen
ziehen Regen und Gewitter ostwärts von
Westen wird es freundlicher einzelne
Schauer sind aber möglich die Temperatur
steigt auf 25 bis 34 ganz im Norden auf
22 bis 25 Grad
am Dienstag wird es noch mal bis 36 Grad
danach ist die große Hitze vorbei morgen
übernimmt hier mit Sirin das gesamte
heute Team sagt tschüss und wünscht
Ihnen einen guten Start in die neue
Woche